okay welcome back so now I'm going to
tell you about one of the things that I
think is neatest about linear optimal
control design which is the fact that if
I have a linear system that is
controllable and observable I can
develop an optimal full state feedback
control using lqr okay I can also
develop an optimal common filter or
linear quadratic estimator using a and C
and what's amazing is that when I
combine them they remain optimal so I
choose this lqr to place the eigenvalues
of the closed-loop system here I choose
the common filter games to place the
eigenvalues of my estimator dynamics and
it's not obvious but it's very cool that
when I combine these I retain those same
dynamics okay so this combined system
where I estimate the full state then I
do lqr
given Gaussian white noise disturbances
and measurement noise this is called the
linear quadratic Gaussian control and in
practice we call it lq g l q g so it's
again linear control that minimizes a
quadratic cost function and here it's
given gaussian disturbances for my full
state estimation so lq g is a pretty
neat control it's essentially just
combining a common filter and an lq r it
does have some limitations so there are
some fundamental issues that when you
combine these things sometimes your LQG
system can suffer from robustness issues
sometimes your system can be like
arbitrarily fragile meaning if this has
a little bit of system uncertainty or
some nonlinear dynamics you didn't model
this could in general become unstable
even if you think it should be stable
that's something we'll talk about later
and that actually motivates what's
called robust control which is optimal
and a difference
but for now let's just combine these and
make sure that the dynamics of the
combined system has the same eigenvalues
we think it should have so what I want
to do is remember first of all we have
epsilon equals x minus x hat and we had
some epsilon dot dynamics that I'll
remind you of in a minute but what I
want to check is that X dot so DDT of X
is equal to all of this stuff okay it's
equal to ax plus B u but remember U is
minus K so u equals minus kr X hat we're
using the estimate of X because we don't
have access to the full states times our
our lq our gain matrix so this is really
a minus b KR x hat okay plus some
disturbances okay and so now what we get
to do is think to ourselves well what is
X hat well X hat I what I can do is I
can essentially say X hat is equal to X
minus X minus X hat sounds reasonable I
think and so I'm going to plug this in
here this is just an identity I'm going
to plug that in here
and I'm going to get a X minus BK are X
minus minus is plus BK are X minus X hat
plus WD no big deal okay
and if you recall the dynamics of our
epsilon if I looked at epsilon dot I'm
pretty sure I got something like a minus
my calman filter gains times C epsilon
and I didn't actually derive this for
the case with disturbance and
noise but if you do what you get is a
plus W D so this w D essentially feeds
through and then I also get a minus KS
times my sensor noise so you can just
verify I do this on some pencil and
paper and verify that you get these
terms but it's pretty simple and so now
what I want to do is I want to combine
these two so I want to build a new state
space equation D DT of my true state X
this is the actual state of the actual
system I want you to be stabilized and
the error of my estimation I also want
this to be stabilized so X is my
honest-to-goodness full state epsilon is
my estimation error so I want both of
these to be stable and if I write this
down what I have is okay so I'm going to
write this down as a matrix times hope
that I have enough room here times X and
epsilon okay so X dot equals a minus BK
x kr is a column and filter I also have
a plus B K epsilon so there's a B K R
here and then there is I'm not going to
have another matrix times my
disturbances and noise so to some extent
in my calming filter system the
disturbances and noise are kind of the
exogenous inputs to my system so there
I'm writing them kind of like an input
and in this equation I had a V an
identity and a 0 here okay because
disturbance feeds through to X dot but
not sensor noise okay and now my epsilon
dot equation I have this doesn't depend
at all on X which is amazing so 0 then I
have a minus calm and filter see ok so
this is getting pretty cool and then I
have an identity on my disturbance and a
minus KF on my noise
and so this is really really remarkable
when I take and I actually combined my
full se Testament from my common filter
with an L Q are optimal full state
feedback control I can get I can derive
the dynamics for X and epsilon and what
I get is the eigenvalues of this coupled
system because this is a diagonal I get
the eigenvalues of this matrix and the
eigenvalues of this matrix so what's
really cool is even when I combine these
systems the eigenvalues of my full state
X are still stabilized by my lqr
controller so this is my kind of lqr
eigenvalues their optimal from lqr and
my estimator dynamics retain the exact
same calman filter eigenvalues my calmer
filter or lq e eigenvalues and so in
control theory this is called the
separation principle separation
principle which essentially means I can
design my lqr and my lqe controllers and
estimators in isolation separately and
when I combine them the combined system
retains the desirable properties of each
of them this is really really cool it
just works out because of the linear
algebra so we can actually take a real
system with limited measurements limited
actuation and we can build both of these
and put them together and so that's what
we're going to do next
and for some cases we're going to find
that this does have the robustness
issues so we're going to generalize this
optimal control framework to try to find
controllers that are optimal with
respect to other cost functions like
maybe I want to penalize fragility and
which will define later okay thank you